Before we jump into using Niagara, we're going to take a quick look at Niagara as a whole
and get more information about what we are using so we better understand how things are set up and they work.
Now the first thing that we want to talk about with Niagara is inheritance.
And that's because inheritance plays a massive role inside of Niagara.
So each Niagara system that you create is actually going to be a collection of Niagara admitters.
Those admitters are actually a collection of dynamic input scripts, functions, and modules.
And those are further made up of Niagara asset tags, data channels, effects types, parameter collections,
parameter collection instances, definitions, simulation caches, and rules.
So you can see here that all of the things that you might work on inside of Niagara are actually created of bits of smaller VFX.
So you can kind of think of Niagara as creating material instances but for VFX.
Now because Niagara is such a complex editor, when you go to create a new admitter,
you're going to be greeted with this wizard.
The wizard allows you to select template to get started from and it's also a great resource when you're learning
because it's going to show you a bunch of different examples of things that you can create.
Now the Niagara editor is going to look similar to many of the other editors you used with the file menu across the top.
And then one, much like with Blueprints and with the material editor, we have our save and our browse to asset and our compile.
The thumbnail controls our thumbnail or this is what it's going to look like when viewed inside of the content browser.
Our bounds shows us the rendering bounds, debug will show us debug information, simulation is for playing the simulation.
Baker allows us to bake out this to a texture and scalability controls what is going to be turned on and turned off for our scalability.
So again the menu bar here is very, very similar to what you've used in the past with other editors.
Over here, two, this is going to be our preview window. This will show us the effect as we are building upon it.
Now three over here, this is going to be our parameters, user parameters and local modules.
Now out of this one, the one that we're going to use the most here is going to be user parameters and we'll cover those in just a little bit.
Over here four, this is going to be our timeline, curves, Niagara log and script stats.
Now the timeline doesn't necessarily work in the way that you might be thinking.
It doesn't actually control the parameters inside of here. Since this Niagara system can have multiple admitters in here,
we can actually have different admitters and then control them through the timeline down here.
Curves allow us to control the curves that we are working with.
So if we have something that's going maybe from like an alpha from zero to one back to zero, we can look at that curves in the Curve Editor with more detail.
Niagara log is going to show us the Niagara logs and the script stats are going to show us the stats of the whole system.
Five is going to be our details panel. Now like with many of the other details panel in the editor, this is context sensitive.
So what we have selected is going to change that.
And then finally, six is our system overview and this is where we're going to be doing a majority of our work here.
We can select each of these individual modules inside of this Niagara system right here.
The details panels will populate with them and that is where we're going to do the work.
So speaking of populating with it, the item that we're looking at here is called the stack.
And the stack is basically where we interact with our particle.
So you can see here we have an Admitter Summary, then we have our Admitter Spawn, our Admitter Update, and then our Particle Spawn, our Particle Update, and the Renderer.
So the Admitter Spawn and the Admitter Update can be thought of as the things that get started.
So this is what is going to start to admit all of our particles.
And then the Particle Spawn and the Particle Update can be thought of as well, this is what we're actually going to be seeing.
And if you press, you can either collapse these by pressing this little triangle, or you can add different modules by pressing the plus sign next to each one of these stages.
Once you do that, you're going to see this new module list come up and there are an awful lot of modules here.
So keep that in mind that if you're looking for something to do with these, it's probably going to be there.
You're probably going to need to search for it.
In addition, each of the inputs you have here have the ability to be set up to either a parameter, or we can further implement something like an expression, or we can multiply them by a little formula or something like that.
So we have a huge amount of control around our particles inside of Niagara.
Now there is one other thing that I want to talk about that you might run into, and that is a lightweight admitter or a stateless admitter.
You can have this type of admitter working with another Niagara admitter in the same Niagara.
And what the difference between this one and a standard Niagara admitter is that a lightweight admitter reduces the concurrent cost per tick, and in essence what it is is a reduced version of a particle system that is just the bare basics that is needed for it to run.
So these are really good for things, maybe like a fire or an ambient smoke that doesn't need all of the various options that Niagara comes with.
We just need something very simple.
So we can add a lightweight admitter and then you'll see there'll be some parameters that we can add to it, but not as many as we normally would.
So with that said, the next thing we're going to do is we are going to get into creating our first Niagara effect.